nancy pelosi's january 6 commission
kicked off yesterday
with a star performance from one of the
two liberal republicans
who agreed to sit on the otherwise
entirely democrat panel
ladies and gentlemen without further ado
adam kinzinger
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
to my colleagues on the committee
thank you to our witnesses uh i never
expected a day to be
quite as emotional for me as it has been
i've talked to
a number of you and gotten to know you
i think it's important to tell you right
now though
you guys may like individually feel a
little broken
you guys all talk about the effects you
have to deal with and
you know you talk about the impact of
that day
but you guys won
you guys held
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
we're defined by how we come back from
bad bad days
how we take accountability for that
and for all the overheated rhetoric
surrounding this committee
our mission is very simple let's define
the truth
and it's to ensure accountability encore
encore mr i've got to wipe a tear from
my eye for reaction
to kinzinger's whining we turn as usual
to don corleone
you can act like a man what's the matter
with you
is this how you turn around a hollywood
binocular that cries like a woman
what can i do what can i do
ridiculous ridiculous it is ridiculous
kinzinger's statements were ridiculous
but his womanish clown show was the role
to which court jester conservatives such
as he are best suited in our national
drama
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from escariana who
says
the people saying that you don't need to
disclose your hiv
results to your sexual partners or the
same people saying you're responsible
for their health so you must get
vaccinated
yes this is true and it's it's basically
pointless
to to try to make sense of it it's not
about a uniform standard it's not about
it's not even about their hypocrisy it's
it's hierarchy
as is often said these days there are
just different rules for different
people
and you my friend if you in any way
dissent from the liberal regime
you are on the wrong side of that and
that's just the way it goes now if you
want to
get strong if you want to you know just
start feeling a little bit better
even i know everyone's keeping you down
but you want to start feeling better i
would strongly recommend
echelon fitness i absolutely love
echelon it is phenomenal
echelon is the affordable way to get
workout equipment the workout community
and the instructor's motivation right in
the comfort of your own home
echelon's fitness app provides you
thousands of live and on-demand classes
with great music from your favorite
artists you pick your class you climb up
the leaderboard
you cheer each other on you give it your
all echelon certified fitness
instructors they're supportive
they're engaging they're fun they'll
give you a great workout echelon's full
range of affordable workout equipment
includes stationary bikes smart rowers
sleek fitness screens or the auto
folding treadmill they're all connected
to provide the echelon experience
they've got around-the-clock classes for
the family they've got full body workout
programs
that keep you coming back one membership
covers a family
of five really really strongly
recommend these guys especially you know
you don't want to drive to the gym you
got to drive to the gym you get changed
you do this you do that no you do it
right in the comfort of your own home
it's great right now get an echelon ex-3
bike
risk free for 30 days plus free shipping
and assembly to get this exclusive offer
with these free bonuses valued at two
hundred and fifty dollars
go to echelonfit.com knowles that's
e-c-h-e-l-o-n-f-i-t
dot com slash knowles for this free
offer echelonfit.com
knowles today you guys you today you
adam ginziger really he didn't he didn't
surprise anyone with his performance
least of all himself i'm sure he was
practicing that one in the mirror like
any ham actor about to get the hook
but it is worth pointing out that not
only were the
the tiers preposterous but the
statements that he made
were preposterous as well he said
that the capital incident in january was
an insurrection
it was not an insurrection the the way
that we know
in part that this was not or here's some
evidence that this was not an
insurrection
the weight of the federal government
right now is
trying to prosecute anyone who was in
any way involved in that day
it's not like blm where they all get off
the hook or most of them get off the
hook
everyone is trying to prosecute these
guys to the fullest extent of the law
and yet no one is being charged with
seditious conspiracy
no one is being charged with the crimes
associated with
insurrection they're being charged with
criminal trespassing they're being
charged with all sorts of things like
property damage theft but they're not
being charged
with sedition because the feds can't
prove that it was an insurrection
because it wasn't
it was a deadly insurrection well it was
deadly
one person was killed in the violence of
that day
it was a trump supporter it was one of
the people who went into the capital
so i get if if you're saying that it was
a deadly insurrection and that's a
terrible thing
then you should be grilling the cops
that you otherwise were praising all day
because a cop killed a trump supporter
that was the only
i know that we were told in the
aftermath by a bunch of liars
in the establishment media and
in the establishment the political
establishment like adam kinzinger and
all of the democrats
we were told that officer brian sicknick
was killed because someone threw a
fire extinguisher in his head that just
wasn't true that was completely made up
he died of natural causes
days later that's what happened no one
else died another person died of a drug
overdose other people died of natural
causes
the only person who died in political
violence was
one of the pro-trump demonstrators
okay this was the worst attack on our
democracy
since 1812 the political commentator
yossi gestetner
had a wonderful threat on this the other
day you probably didn't see it on
twitter because i imagine it was
suppressed
he pointed out that the january sixth
insurrection
uh that involved some damage to the
capital no question about it
there have been other attacks on the
capital it wasn't the worst one since
1812. in 19 this is just just from his
list from yossi's list
1954 five congressmen were wounded when
four terrorists opened fire in the
visitors area
president carter later commuted their
sentences or reduced their sentences so
that seems worse than january 6. doesn't
it at 1971
a bomb planted by a group or person
protesting the vietnam war so this would
have been a left winger
exploded in the senate wing of the
capital caused extensive damage
thankfully no injuries that seems worse
than january 6. november 7th 1983
an explosion tore through the second
floor of the capitol's north wing
that the device blew the door off of
democrat leader robert byrd's office
seems worse than january 6 1998 two
capitol police officers
jacob chestnut jr and john gibson died
in the line of duty because an armed
assailant
stormed past the capital security
checkpoint and he made it into the
building where he was shot seems worse
than january 6th
before midnight on 19 in 1915
police responded to the capital where an
explosion caused huge damage to the
senate wing
then in october of 2018 hundreds of
leftists stormed the u.s senate building
during the work of confirming a supreme
court justice
302 people were arrested by capitol hill
police
no people were left arrested by the
federal government and then last year
in the summer of hate in 2020 when blm
was burning down the country
the president and his family were rushed
to the white house bunker as
insurrectionists i get you gotta use the
term right you gotta if you're gonna use
the term for the horn guys certainly you
need to use the term for the people who
stormed the white house
scaled the fence and 60 secret service
agents were wounded
in the process 11 of them needing
hospitalization
for defending the white house the horn
guy comes in the smiley guy steals
pelosi's podium that was the worst
insurrection in history
but just months prior people stormed the
white house
and wound 60 secret service agents 11 of
them sent to the hospital
that was nothing that truly you probably
didn't even hear about that or you heard
very little or all you heard from the
media
were people making fun of president
trump for going into the bunker
so i just don't want to hear it i don't
want to hear it i never want to hear
another word
about january 6th the it's compared
to other attacks that you've never even
heard of they didn't even make the news
really or they are not they don't remain
in the public consciousness
what happened on january 6th was
relatively insignificant
moreover moreover and this is i think
the big problem that the january 6
commission is having
as the media narrative fades and as more
and more evidence is presented of what
actually happened on january 6th
the narrative is falling apart it's
further falling we were told that these
angry crazy trump supporters were
showing up to the capitol and
throwing things for windows meanwhile
what what you're seeing
is video emerging of trump supporters
coming up to the cops and saying guys
stop this there are people who are
infiltrating their stuff but we don't
like what's going on
stop defend the capitol
[Music]
so obviously there are a lot of
theories about what's going on who's
breaking into the capital it was antifa
no it wasn't it was the maga people no
was this no was that
that that's sort of beside the point the
question is why weren't the cops doing
anything in some cases you see the cops
like standing down
and letting people go into the capitol
that's going to really complicate the
narrative so
because of this because more and more
video evidence is coming out
that paints the maga people in a much
better light than we were told by the
mainstream media
now you're you're seeing testimony from
some cops and other people
who are just creating whole new
narratives saying that actually it was a
bunch of racists
and and the naga people they called me
the n word
one woman in a pink mega shirt yelled
you hear that guys this voted for joe
biden
then the crowd perhaps around 20 people
joined in screaming boom
no one had ever ever
called me in while wearing the uniform
of a capitol police officer
in the days following the attempted
insurrection
other black officers shared with me
their own stories of racial abuse on
january 6th
one officer told me he had never
and in his his entire 40 years of life
been called in to his face and that
streak
ended on january 6. yet
another black officer later told me he
had been
confronted by insurrectionists in the
capital
who told him put your gun down
and we'll show you what kind of you
really are
yeah did they take your subway sandwich
too did they tell you this was
magga country and it was on the side of
chicago forgive me my skepticism
but there are thousands of videos of
just about every angle of every
just about everything that happened that
day cameras everywhere
i don't see any evidence of this
whatsoever and trust me
if this had happened if there were even
one second a video of this this would
have been blasted on every major news
now i'm not saying there's no way it
happened
i'm just saying forgive my skepticism
that the
liberal establishment that has lied to
us about every
single aspect of this event might not be
telling the truth
right now you know why
i don't believe that as this one capitol
hill officer says he was
called awful racial epithets by all of
the trump supporters you know what
not even that i don't believe do you
know why i'm skeptical of this claim
because this that word
the n-word which the capitol hill
officer just says he's saying it
for full effect in the room we bleep it
on the shows but he's saying it for full
effect
that word is the unutterable word
you don't hear people say that you
certainly don't hear people say that in
public there's no video of anyone saying
that
on january 6th despite all of the videos
of that day
much of that event was live streamed
there were don't the cops wear body
cameras where is it where is
any evidence oh they don't have any
so they've just got the testament not
only do they have the testimony they got
the testimony of this one guy
who shows up and he says yeah but you
know i heard from other guys too that
some other guys and the cousin of the
other guy
and the third cousin once removed the
brother-in-law the guy said that some
other guy said the n-word so basically
trump supporters are bigots uh sorry
i just don't buy it this guy morgan
wallin the country singer
this country singer used the n-word not
in a in a confrontational way not in an
earnest way as though to put someone
down on the basis of his race
but just in the colloquial colloquial
way that you hear in rap music and you
hear in the popular culture
he used it drunkenly privately with his
friend while he was calling him a bunch
of other words in a joking manner
and his life because he just uttered
this in a
joking way you know in a private moment
his life is ruined
take a listen he's only sitting down
because he wants to clean up his
image he's all a performance
so what do you say to that i understand
that you know i understand that that
i'm not ever going to make you know
everyone happy
i can only come tell my truth and and
that's all i know to do it was
in our minds it's playful you know i
don't i don't know if that sounds
ignorant but that's really where it came
from
and and it's and it's wrong and do you
know the history of the word
oh yeah i've heard some stories in the
in the initial conversations that i had
after that just how
just how some people are you know
treated even still today
and i'm just like i haven't seen that
with my eyes that pain or that
that insignificant feeling or whatever
it is that it makes you feel do you
understand
why it makes black people so upset i
don't know how to put myself in their
shoes because i'm not you know but
i i do understand especially when i when
i say that i'm using it playfully or
whatever ignorantly
i understand that that must sound you
know like he doesn't he doesn't
understand
so pathetic and this guy it's been going
on for months now and the
guy's career is over and his life is
over
and i yeah i don't encourage people to
use offensive language i think it's a
bad idea i try not to do it myself
is this a crime against humanity is this
is this the worst thing you can possibly
do well
in our culture it is and so you're
telling me
that a group of trump supporters
in public on camera just started
screaming this word in
earnest in malice and vitriol at a
capitol hill police officer
not buying that now i think there are a
handful of people who use this word
earnestly
or who seem to use this word earnestly
in america
they are the white supremacists i assume
97
of them are fbi informants i think the
entire membership of the ku klux klan is
just different fbi informants and
forming on other fbi informants
pathetic pathetic stuff that the
the left is trying to muster they don't
have the video evidence they don't have
the audio evidence they don't have they
obviously have no answer for the blm
riots and that comparison so
they just create they just put on a show
and it's adam kinzinger and it's
other people as well speaking of not
being able to say things
some republican congressman paul gosar
matt gates
and marjorie taylor green tried to put
on a press conference to get their side
of the argument out on the alleged
insurrection
of course it was shut down by leftist
protesters they owe
the people of this country the answers
to the questions
okay the left is interrupting the press
conference we need to end it
thank you for those of you that really
care about due process
thank you
[Applause]
all right they chased them down the
street i think that was louis gomer
there at the end
it's become tedious and cliche to say
imagine if the situation were reversed
because the situation isn't reversed
because power is not balanced in any way
in this country
but if there were democratic congressmen
who were out there
talking about you know their side of the
story right maybe defending blm
and and going after january 6th and a
bunch of trump supporters came up with
signs saying sit down you're traitors
and rapists which is what those signs
said
that would be called an insurrection
right that would be called an
interference with our democracy those
people very well might be arrested
the painting of this would be so so uh
different and so
i just don't want to hear it i'm just
absolutely sick of the january 6th thing
as our
as are americans there's a new new poll
out
from rasmussen shows that more americans
want
blm investigated than the capital riot
you know adam kinzinger during his
sob story at the top during the
waterworks display
he said i like so many americans i'm
frustrated that we don't have answers
about
january no actually more americans want
blm investigated and kinzinger was asked
about that
and he said it's totally different it's
totally different
yes maybe the blm people committed some
crimes
but but the conservatives who storm the
capital they
threaten the rule of law itself so blm
which which burned down federal
courthouses
blm which torched police stations blm
which scaled the fence at the white
house they did not threaten that was
just a little crime
that's you know a minor thing slap on
the wrist but
the smiling florida guy who took
pelosi's lectern that's the threat to
the rule of law itself
according to rasmussen one third
more americans believe that congress
should hold investigative hearings
about the blm riots than uh the january
6th probe but
that's not going to happen so who cares
i think that probably the best course of
action
is you know obviously we have to talk
about it with this launch of the january
6th commission
but i think basically as a rule
republican certainly on capitol hill
should ignore it it's preposterous
it's a tale told by an idiot full of
sound and fury signifying nothing
it just doesn't matter speaking of polls
there's a new poll out that shows
some good news in california a poll
conducted by uc berkeley and the l.a
times so not exactly conservative
institutions okay one of the most
left-wing schools in the country
and a left-wing newspaper the poll shows
that california voters
are just about evenly split on recalling
gavin newsom so the question is
one will gavin newsom be recalled and
then if he is recalled
who replaces him and you know that our
friend larry elder is is now running
offering a genuinely conservative
alternative to gavin newsom
who has name recognition who has the
ability to raise some money
much better than the choice of mr mr
bruce jenner who
as far as i can tell is more left-wing
than any other gannet in the race
the poll found that 47 of likely voters
support removing newsome 50 opposed
removing newsome
the difference is just shy of the
survey's margin of error according even
to the la times
this is really shocking california is a
deep deep democrat state this this poll
should not even come
close newsome should have this thing
locked by a landslide and yet he doesn't
because i think some people are
beginning to wake up even on the
democrat side and that that is a cause
for hope
speaking of the run for governor larry
elder you'll remember because he's the
greatest threat to gavin newsom right
now on the republican side
larry elder was not being permitted on
the ballot
so they were trying to rule that larry
elder filled out some form wrong or
something
and that he he couldn't be on the ballot
well thankfully a
judge has just ruled that larry elder
absolutely can appear on the ballot
so if newsom is recalled there's a rea
there's actually a chance
now i know there's widespread mail-in
votes i know that there's motor voter
and ballot harvesting i know the
democrats are
rigging this thing as best they can to
prevent a republican from winning but
there actually is a chance which is
pretty
pretty good news and it's not a moment
too soon because california
is heading for a lockdown again all
right they're already
requiring masks even among vaccinated
people indoors
now joe biden is coming out and he's
he's complaining that at the national
level
unless everybody gets vaccinated
then we are really in for trouble and
he's
turning up the crotchetiness you know
joe biden for all of his career was just
this glib
backslabbing simpering sort of guy with
the big smile who would kiss babies that
was his whole thing but in his old age
he's becoming much more ornery
and so he's come out now he's accusing
unvaccinated people of sowing confusion
he's attacking their intelligence this
is not just going to be limited
to california and to new york as i have
said now
for what i don't know 15 months or
something like that
the 15 days to slow the spread is never
going to end people don't like giving up
power and so there's going to be the
the delta variant and then they've
already set up the lambda variant and
then there's the sigma variant and
there's going to be the phi beta kappa
variant
and there's the deek variant and the
pike and the vibe and the
delta and the zelta and the belta and
whatever it's just going to go on
forever and ever and ever
you might say we're heading into an
authoritarian moment
speaking of which ben's new book the
authoritarian moment is available at
amazon barnes noble or any other major
bookseller so get your copy now
and leave a five-star review to help
amplify conservative voices you can also
be able to
cut out the book flap and use that as a
campaign sticker when i run on the
slogan knowles 2028
the authoritarian moment tonight you can
hear about the book by joining me ben
shapiro jeremy boring matt walsh
andrew clavin special guest candace
owens for an
extra exciting cigar packed session of
backstage
streams at 7 pm eastern 6 pm central on
dailywire.com and on our daily wire
youtube channel do not miss it and for a
limited time
enter to win a backstage vip pass to
visit the daily wire studios meet your
backstage hosts
get a swag bag of daily wire merch
including autographed books new daily
wire members are automatically entered
to win
so go to dailywire.com subscribe get 25
off a new membership today with code
backstage we'll be right back with a lot
more
no more mr nice biden old uncle joe
is turning up the heat on unvaccinated
americans he's saying they're sowing
confusion
and they're not smart will you require
all federal employees to get vaccinated
that's under consideration right now but
if you're not vaccinated you're not
nearly as smart as i thought you were
are you concerned that the cec guidance
could show confusion
we have a pandemic because the
unvaccinated and there's so many
enormous confusion
and the more we learn the more we learn
about this virus and the build of
variation the more we have to be worried
and concerned
and the only one thing we know for sure
if those
other 100 million people got vaccinated
we'd be in a very different world
so get vaccinated if you haven't you're
not really as smart as i said
having your intelligence questioned by
joe biden is a badge of honor
okay joe biden and i don't even mean
this because now he's saying things that
are
incoherent in his senility i'm saying
this because for his whole career this
guy was considered to be
among the duller members of our
political class he never he would lie
about his academic credentials but he
was always
sort of toward the bottom of the heap on
the old iq scale
so for him to call you a dummy you know
what does it talk
talk sense to a fool and he calls you
foolish i think in the words of
euripides
joe biden then says we have a pandemic
because of the unvaccinated
i thought we had a pandemic because of
the wuhan wet markets oh no that turned
out to be a lie
i thought we had a pandemic then because
of a naturally
occurring virus that may or may not have
had something to do with the wuhan
laboratory
oh no that turned out to be a lie i
thought we had a pandemic because
of a manipulated virus that did escape
from the wuhan
laboratory okay that's possible but it
wasn't funded by the united states right
oh no that turned out to be a lie
uh it was funded by the united states
but then we have a pandemic
because people are they're they're
touching their faces too much they're
wearing the masks the masks aren't doing
anything gives them a false sense of
security oh no that turned out to maybe
be a lie
at least was contradicted later by the
same people who said it
and told us all to wear the masks and
then told us all to lock down and then
told us this that and the other thing
but no you you who using your faculties
of reason and your prudence don't want
to get the experimental drug because
you're not maybe at the highest risk of
dying from covid you're the problem
you're the problem
the more we learn the more the more we
learn the more we realize that there are
side effects to the
drug to the the shot we know the fda and
the cdc have admitted this
blood clotting from the j j vaccine in
some women
myocarditis in otherwise perfectly
healthy young people
from the mrna vaccines and so maybe you
make a risk calculation if you're
75 or 80 plus you say okay well it's
just worth me worth it because i'm at
greater risk of covid but if you're 15
maybe you're not going to get that
vaccine and it doesn't make you stupid
and it doesn't make you selfish
makes you smart okay they're sowing
confusion the unvaccinated people you
know i think is sowing confusion
i think the liberal establishment and dr
fauci and joe biden
and and all the rest of them i think
they're the ones sowing confusion
people should not be walking around with
masks let me just state
for the record that masks are not
theater
wearing a mask might make people feel a
little bit better and masks are
protective
and but it's not providing the perfect
protection that people think
that it is there has not been any
indication
that putting a mask on and wearing a
mask for a considerable period of time
has any deleterious effects there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
and can you get some schmutz sort of
staying inside there of course
you do not need to wear a mask indoors
if in fact
you've been vaccinated good that you're
vaccinated but in a situation
where you have people indoors
particularly crowded you should wear a
mask
so even if you are vaccinated you should
wear a mask
if in fact you are vaccinated fully
vaccinated you are protected
and you do not need to wear a mask
outdoors or indoors when the children go
out
into the community you want them to
continue to wear masks you know if you
look at
children outside particularly when
they're with the family uh
walking down the street playing a game
or what have you don't have to wear
a mask the the the pediatric the academy
of pediatric
actually makes that recommendation that
children should be wearing masks
uh from two years old yeah stop sowing
confusion you unvaccinated people
just be really clear like dr fauci has
held every single
opinion you can hold on anything
simultaneously
there's a new study out of great britain
shows that five times as many british
children died of suicide as died of
covid a study comes out from the
university of bristol university of york
university of liverpool university
college london
compared morbidity statistics from the
national child morbidity database
with public health england showed
five times as many kids killed
themselves as died of coveted
you're not going to hear about that
you'll hear about it on this show you'll
hear about it from some conservative
atlas you won't hear about it
from many other places because we
focused in on this one
virus the the wuhan cough that now is
the only
thing that matters in the world and so
we take away your rights we take away
your life we take away your
relationships we take away your business
we take away your country we take away
your election integrity
it's all fine so if if it just prevents
one person from getting the cough
then that's all that matters by the way
it might not might not be doing that
either speaking of the brits there is a
shocking new poll out
a shocking new study allegedly that
shows that britons
are willing to ban certain books and
i've seen some conservatives talking
about this but
i think none of them are getting it
quite right so here's here's what the
poll says
would the british public support or
oppose the uk government censoring books
with content that it deems sexist
homophobic or racist
40 support that 30 percent oppose that
24
uh uh say neither pluralities
of uh uh concer
41 says uh yes labor 46
would support uh book bans and we in
america we
recoil from this we say this is
absolutely great we should never ban any
books
this is anathema who we are it's
anathema to the christian west
and that's just not true i think we're
really overstating our case here
there have been plenty of books that
have been banned in the united states
from the very beginning of our country
there are some books that remain banned
or practically banned i mean we
amazon is banning books today right now
what has changed is not that certain
books are being banned
obscene material was banned and heavily
regulated from the very beginning of our
country
and theoretically would still be today
what what has changed is not that some
books are canceled what has changed is
the standards by which books are
cancelled
early on huge swats of political
material if you published a book that
said men are not women
for instance that book would not be
censored today
my friend ryan anderson did publish a
book that said men are not women it's
called when harry became sally
that book is being censored not by the
government but effectively by the
government
it's it's being censored by the liberal
establishment and by the website that
sells 80
of books plus in the united states
okay that's different kind of censorship
i know this is
sort of unpopular to say on the right
right now
but plenty of wise people have
acknowledged
that societies ban certain books and
that it's not the end of the world
plato defended book burning for goodness
sakes plato
from whom we get much if not most of
western philosophy
saint luke in the bible
looks very favorably upon book burning
in the acts of the apostles
there i'm not calling for book burnings
right now i'm making the descriptive
observation
that all societies ban certain books
certain licentious material
certain dangerous material certain
seditious material all societies
including our own
and so long as conservatives live in
this pie in the sky world that has never
existed
where the society does not impose any
standards or taboos on written material
we're going to keep losing because what
the left understands is that all
societies impose those standards and so
they're going to try to pervert the
standards
to their own ends and i think what we
need to do is go back in and say no look
yeah we all grant obscene material
seditious material
this sort of stuff does not have there's
no natural right for this material to
go out there but we want to defend
when harry became sally but we want to
defend important political speech but we
want to defend
the actual american free speech
tradition which happens to be the thesis
of my book which you should not ban
or burn speaking of standards
the senate panel voted to make women
register for the draft we told you that
this was very likely going to happen
last week and then it did happen and i'm
not surprised at all but you know we
started the show talking about the
squishy republicans like
like adam kinzinger there were
republicans on this
committee who voted to draft your
daughters into the armed forces
there were many there were actually only
five republicans who voted against it
so the five republicans on the armed
services committee who voted against
drafting your daughters
were senator james inhofe senator roger
wicker senator tom cotton senator josh
hawley and senator mike rounds
very good stuff you should applaud those
guys that's the right thing
there were one two three four five six
seven eight republicans who voted
to draft your daughters i'm not going to
read their names
you can find them online i'm not going
to read their names
because my point here is not to shame
them and humiliate them and
my point here is to correct them
number of senators here from uh
all over the country who are ostensibly
republican who think that it is
acceptable
to to draft women into the armed forces
it is not
that is not the country that i want to
live in i suspect that's not the country
that you want to live in
that is not a country that is in any way
conservative this is not a country that
recognizes even the most basic
distinction in human nature
between men and women it's hard it's
sometimes it's difficult to find that
distinction especially with
kinzinger bawling his eyes out at the at
the uh
committee hearings but if you can't
conserve the just the very basic
distinction in human nature you can't
conserve anything so i hope these
senators change their mind before this
thing goes up to a real vote
also a point here is some people i think
have misinterpreted what i've said
when i say that adam kinzinger is a
womanish clown
i'm not dissing women most people
understand that but but
there's a difference between being
womanish and womanly
and the difference is this when a woman
embodies the feminine virtues
that's a wonderful beautiful thing when
a man
performs a caricature of a woman that's
a very bad thing
that's one that's the difference between
woman lee and woman-ish and what
kenzinger and a lot of the rest of these
squishes are doing very much the latter
speaking of women in battle
i've got to get to the most important
story that i didn't think was going to
matter but but it does
simone biles simone biles is
apparently an olympic athlete i had
never heard of simone biles until last
night
i don't watch the olympics it's never
particularly interested me
and in the recent years where american
athletes are turning against their
country i'm not saying someone biles did
that
but where a number of athletes are doing
that i'm just not interested at all so
simone biles is apparently a very
popular and accomplished gymnast
and simone biles decided because she
performed badly in some
event that she was just going to quit
the olympics she was sent to the
olympics
to represent the united states to bring
home medals to do
sport battle against other countries
and to bring home medals for the united
states but then she just wasn't feeling
it one day
she just wasn't feeling it so in the
past when olympians have not just
injured their feelings
but injured their bodies they have still
gone on they've still competed they've
still fought
to bring home those medals for the
united states compare as
my friend charlie kirk did on the
internet yesterday compared those good
old days
to simone biles today
[Applause]
here you have an olympian competing with
a broken foot here he strikes
[Music]
[Applause]
and i think we're just a little bit too
stressed out
um but we should be out here having fun
and sometimes
that's not the case okay there's a lot
of variables as to why she quit
and it's she was a little stressed out
and look she's just there to have fun
she's just there for her right
of course not i mean this is this is sad
this is pathetic this is disgraceful
but i don't want to be too hard on
simone biles here
one because i don't know anything about
simone biles and i'm not that interested
but but also
two because i think simone biles
is the voice of her generation i think
is the voice of a generation that was
not
not taught duty that was actually taught
to mock duty it was taught to mock
honor and the things that are higher
than one's own
pleasure and one's own comfort
simone biles as she quits the olympics
because she's got the bad feels she says
i've never felt like this going into a
competition before i tried to go out
there and have fun
and warm up in the back went a little
bit better but then once i came out here
no mental's not there so i just need to
let the girls do it and focus on myself
physically i feel good i'm in shape she
says she said this to the today show
emotionally that kind of varies in the
time and moment coming here to the
olympics and being the head star isn't
an easy feat
so we're just trying to take it one day
at a time and we'll see it's really
really pathetic and disgraceful
because she's not there to have fun and
she's not there for herself
and she's she's not there as just oopsie
daisy
think about the person whose spot she
took
think about the people who spent their
whole lives trying to make it to the
olympics
and then this gal took another gal's
spot
and then because she just didn't have
the right feels that day
she said no i'm not having as much fun
as i used to
ah you know you got the imagine the guys
storming normandy
say ah you know this isn't as fun as it
used to be
imagine you're at your office you've got
a very important project that has to get
done
and then one of the key guys on the team
he says ah you know what guys
it just doesn't i didn't know i'm not
enjoying it as much as i you know good
luck see ya
i'm late i'm quitting it's just it's
just quitting i know some people are
trying to defend her they say
she has mental problems maybe she does i
don't know i mean i know
some people have been blaming it on
mental problems i know a lot of people
are
blaming a lot of things on mental
problems because suffering and grievance
now now carries social currency
but if if this woman really has mental
problems then she's you know she should
never have been competing in the first
place i mean she needs to get the help
that she needs right
or is or is that just an excuse because
she just didn't you know she didn't feel
it
she felt she wasn't competing at her
best and maybe she just doesn't want to
and in our culture there's nothing
nothing more important than one's
will than one's appetite and one's
pleasure and comfort and desire
very sad stuff sad stuff i mean this is
part of this just underscores
my decision not to watch or care about
the olympics at all
here's another thing that does that the
head of the olympics broadcasting
i just came out made a very important
feminist statement
said uh that the olympics broadcasting
coverage
is going to focus on women's sport
appeal
not their sex appeal so the tokyo
olympics head of broadcasting said
they're
they're going to minimize the
sexualization
of female athletes in light of athlete
complaints
that the the uniforms are too sexy or
something
and they want to make the women's bodies
more covered up
and this this head of broadcasting yanis
xarcos says
you got to focus on sport appeal not sex
appeal you will not see in our coverage
some things that we have been seeing in
the past
with details and close-up close-ups on
parts of the body what we can do is make
sure that our coverage does not
highlight our feature in any particular
way
what people are wearing and you won't
see any of that stuff
this is very wrong this is not because
i'm saying that you know
the the olympics should be a striptease
or a burlesque show but
the physical beauty of the olympians
is and has always been a central feature
of the olympics going back to ancient
greece
and actually it extends to all sorts of
sports these people
not even just the way i'm talking about
the men too these are top physical
specimens
these are people who have spent years
and years and years crafting
and their bodies into these machines
into these incredible
specimens of achievement and excellence
so that they can form
perform athletic feats you you can't
separate
the physical appeal of the olympians
from
the sport thems they're intertwined
the objectification this what this is
denying
is the way that we as human beings
relate to our bodies and relate to one
another
we are attracted to one another the
sexes are complementary men and women
are different
in this way and sport is about physical
excellence
it's not just about making the
individual athletes feel good or
something like that
it's about all of us marveling at their
excellence or at least that's what it's
supposed to be
but you can't acknowledge sexual
difference now
forget in sports forget in sports you
cannot acknowledge
sexual difference in medical school
uh this just came out from barry weiss's
sub stack yesterday it's one of the
very voices substance is one of the best
journalistic outlets out there
it's much better than the new york times
and barry weiss isn't even particularly
conservative
so barry weiss had this piece up
during a recent endocrinology course at
a top medical school in the uc system
university of california
system a professor actually stopped
mid-lecture
to apologize for something that he had
said at the beginning of class
what do you think he said you already
know you know the answer before i even
tell you here's what here's what the
professor says
i don't want you to think that i am in
any way trying to imply anything
and if you can summon some generosity to
forgive me
i would really appreciate it was adam
kinzinger teaching this course i don't
know
the physician said this in a recording
that was provided by a student in the
class this is not
hearsay it's not like that that cop who
was testifying
on the january 6 panel i heard from a
friend of a friend of another friend of
a friend who said that these guys were
really mean
the professor goes on again i'm very
sorry for that
it was certainly not my intention to
offend anyone
the worst thing that i can do as a human
being is be offensive
pause there for a second before we even
get to what he said
the worst thing you can do is be
offensive
murder pillage rape genocide
uh no be offensive that's the worst
thing
right that's i don't think i don't think
being offensive is the worst thing
that you can do as a human being
sometimes it's one of the best things
you can do
if what you are offending are the
vicious errors
of a great many people and what was his
offense
you know the answer his offense was
using the term
pregnant women i said when a woman is
pregnant which implies that only women
can get pregnant and i most sincerely
apologize to all of you
oh my gosh why why did the professor
do this why does a medical school
professor
apparently not understand well i guess
he does understand that only women can
get pregnant but why is he lying about
that then and why is he apologizing
about that because he i guess he doesn't
know the difference between men
and women where is don
corleone when you need him we need we
need a little bit of this
i'm reminded of the bio tapestry bishop
odo there the battle of hastings
he's smacking his own men with a club it
says here bishop odo comforts the troops
sometimes comfort requires tough love it
means to give strength
where is it sometimes you can act like a
man
what's the matter with you i'm michael
knows this the michael knowles show i'll
see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico associate producer justine
turley
audio mixer mike coromina and hair and
makeup
by nika geneva michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2021. john bickley
here
editor-in-chief of daily wire wake up
every morning with our new show
morning wire on today's show the
floodgates open on vaccine mandates
the refund the police movement gains
momentum and troops withdraw from the
middle east
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with
our show morning wire